[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAMI ZUHURUDDIN: Good afternoon.
My name is Sami Zuhuruddin.
I'm a staff solution architect
on the Cloud platform team.
I'm going to be talking to you
today about cloud forensics.
Cloud forensics machine learning
server, this DevOps quantum
computing forensics edge--
no, that would be a great talk.
That's like everything
I could throw in there.
No, this talk is
called Forensics 101
and I hope by the title
that sort of clued folks in.
The 101 is we're starting
with the fundamentals,
we're starting with
the basics, and then
from there, we're advancing.
We wouldn't be in much shape
talking about advanced subjects
if we weren't
covering the basics,
so that's definitely
kind of the level set.
We're going to talk about
techniques, practices,
things you need to do
for your environment,
and hopefully leave you with
a lot of practical things
that you can do.
This is not necessarily
a talk about security.
We do a lot to secure
our environments
and perfect security is a goal.
Perfect security should
be the outcome or the goal
of any security program.
But we live in a world
where infiltrations happen.
That's just,
unfortunately, the reality.
We hear about them, and
when we hear about them,
they're not great.
Sometimes we don't
hear about them.
They're taken care
of internally.
But when we do hear about them,
they've been, in some cases--
you know, it's not uncommon
to hear months or years that
something has been
allowed to sit there--
some bad actor has been allowed
to act in our environment.
And they're up to no good.
They're up to stealing from us.
It could be stealing
sensitive customer data.
our trade secrets.
It could be stealing literally
half a penny at a time.
That would make a great movie.
But maybe it's not a half a
penny, maybe it's half a coin.
In this case, maybe
it's half a bitcoin.
That's not an
uncommon application,
where they're literally stealing
your computing resources.
But regardless, they're
in our infrastructure.
And if we turn it into
an engineering problem
for a second, our goal
is to optimize the time
from which they
have possibly landed
on our infrastructure
or our environment
to the time we were able to
detect and get rid of it.
We want to optimize to
minimize dwell time.
We want to get-- you know,
from the time they figure out
how to create an
exploit to the time
that we're able to do
something about that,
we want that to be as
little as possible,
because the longer we
allow that to fester,
that's money potentially lost.
So what are the
objectives for today?
What also amazes me is
that, yes, infiltrators
are making their way
into our infrastructure
despite security
measures, but it's also,
when these stories come out
about how things happen,
it's fascinating to watch
the process and progression
that professionals
in that space,
because they are looking at
how to uncover the bad guys,
the process they go through.
And kind of one of
the fundamental pieces
is that it's not magic.
It's forensic.
They're looking at data, much
like any other profession.
They're looking at
pieces of evidence
that allow them to formulate
a certain pattern of behavior
and then uncover things.
So today's activity largely
focuses around that activity.
We're going to talk
about a number of things
we need to be doing
in our environments
to help that process along.
We're going to go over
the tools explicitly.
This is kind of
the highest level
that we'll get to in the talk.
The rest of the talk will talk
about tools and configurations
of tools and things
that we can do.
Also, at the end,
we'll sort of wrap up
with an example of what a whole
forensics pipeline looks like.
This is Cloud and
so it wouldn't be
complete without
talking about things
we can do in an automated
fashion to really sort of make
our whole forensics activities
within our environments
a little more seamless.
All right.
So standard disclaimer.
Going through your
environments and looking
for what a bad actor
may be doing and try
to uncover it and try to get
it out of your environment.
It's serious business.
It shouldn't be taken lightly.
There is tradecraft
out there for those
who are trained to look
at incident response
to find a bad guy within
your infrastructure
and it's our job to help them.
It's our job to
really put together
a very concise and
very well-curated
set of information that allows
those individuals-- if you're
here, that's great, but allows
those individuals to minimize
the amount of time that
something bad is inside
of our environment.
And I kind of analogize this
to being medically informed
and making sort of
the good choices
when it comes to sort of
your diet or your exercise
or things, you can get away
with googling a bunch of stuff
to live really a good life,
but at some point or another,
you have to decide, you know,
it's time to call in a doctor.
It's time to sort of step it up.
And that's the way I'd encourage
you to look at the information
we're going to present here.
It is pretty handy
and it does sort
of open your eyes
to what's available
but try not to be over-cavalier
and know when to bring
in the right resources.
All right.
So we're going to walk
through these stages.
These are sort of
different stages of--
or categories of activities
that we want to walk through
in the process of helping
prepare our environment
for dealing with an incident.
If an incident happens, we
want to be as well-prepared
as we can.
It's going to suck.
It's not something we
want to go through.
But we can either be
extremely poorly prepared,
in which case we just
don't know where to start--
we're literally starting
at square 0, square 1--
or we can be in a
much better position.
And that's our
objective here today
is to be in a much
better position.
And generally, we sort
of move to the right
of this orchestration of
events, but our activities
are going to fall
in this bucket.
And today, just to sort of,
you know, in full transparency,
today we're really going to
be talking about collection.
This is really how
we boost our position
and give an analyst
or somebody that's
investigating an incident
the best ammunition to sort
of move forward.
I said we're going to talk
about collection mainly
but it wouldn't be
complete without talking
about prevention,
and by that, I mean
these are the kinds of
activities that we go through
in securing our infrastructure.
And in a high level,
you could think of it
as the three-step
sort of processes.
Secure your perimeter, go
through defense in depth,
and then monitor how you're
doing at any given point.
But the reason this
is important-- this
is sort of a symbiotic talk.
I mean, there's so
many talks regarding
securing your infrastructure
and how to properly lock things
down, but insofar as when
we talk about it in today's
context or in the context of
forensics, the reason we do
this is, on its own value,
it's incredibly needed
within our environments,
but if we don't do it,
we're going to generate a bunch
of noise-- a bunch of garbage.
And this is sort of
the adage of, you know,
garbage in, garbage out.
If we've left everything
wide open to the internet
and we're just being
bombarded with attacks,
we don't want to float through
a bunch of needless information
to our downstream processes
or our downstream analyses.
We need to take care of making
sure things like our software
pedigree-- if we are
building software
and we're sourcing components
from different locations,
are we keeping up
with the security
bulletins or the vulnerability
bulletins with those libraries?
If we're not, then
that's something
obviously an attacker is
going to find and leverage
and say, oh, they're
using unpatched version x.
We can use a well-known exploit.
So these are activities that
absolutely must be done,
and if you don't
do it, then it's
not only just sort of
weakening your environment.
It's going to make
it so that we're
going to end up crying
wolf a bunch of times
and making it really
difficult for a professional
to come in and properly
analyze the environment.
And by the way, I
mean, not only is
it time is money in terms
of how quickly we uncover
where a bad actor has planted
something in our environment.
These resources generally
that are doing the analysis,
they cost money.
You want them to
come in and you want
them to sort of not have
to waste a lot of time
on finding the needle
in the haystack.
So a great Englishman
once said, who
here likes audience
participation?
Let's organize into
groups of 20-- no, let's
not organize into groups of 20.
Let's call it out.
What are some things
that sort of cause one
to think that they have
an incident going on
or somebody has found a way
into their infrastructure?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SAMI ZUHURUDDIN:
Spiked resource usage.
Maybe the-- go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Anomalous
network traffic.
SAMI ZUHURUDDIN: Anomalous
network traffic, serverless.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Blackmail.
SAMI ZUHURUDDIN: Blackmail.
Ransom notes.
So there's a lot of
things that go on.
The point is, all those people
are probably in the craft--
and the point is,
everybody should
have an incident response plan.
If you don't, look around.
It sounds like there's
about 400 of us
here that might be
able to help out.
But we should have
an incident response
plan to know what to do.
It could be literally
some authority or some law
enforcement that's
come and said,
we have reason to believe that
you're sending a lot of data
to places you shouldn't
be sending data.
So whatever it is, think
about yourself in that moment.
And what are you going
to do if somebody says,
you know, there is strong
evidence here that you're
going to be compromised?
So this is in that
list of to-dos.
I'm going to give you a
couple of not-to-dos, OK?
First one is do not simply
say, oh my gosh, I'm panicked.
I don't know what to do.
Somebody is in my
infrastructure.
I know what to do.
This is Cloud.
I'll hit Delete.
We don't want to do this
for a couple of reasons.
Number one is it just completely
obliterates the forensic trail
that you want to follow.
But in the chess match of-- if
you think about it that way--
if you think about somebody
trying to figure out
how to take advantage
of your infrastructure,
you've made a very naive move.
You've told your opponent
that you really maybe
don't have a game plan.
You haven't figured things out.
And if they were
unaggressive at that point,
they're going to get highly
aggressive after they
see that you're onto them.
Maybe they're going to step
up exfiltrating all your data.
Maybe they're going to
step up their attack.
Maybe they're going to lock you
out of their infrastructure.
So you will obviously
terminate your infrastructure,
but do it at the right time.
Don't make a naive move that
accelerates things needlessly.
The key point is, take a small
breath, say, I have a plan.
I know what to do.
I'm not going to give away my
hand and reveal to an attacker
that I know they're
in my infrastructure.
Don't be a hero.
Do not grab-- don't just,
you know, we're infiltrated.
I know what to do.
I got this.
I'll just log into the server
using SSH so it's secure.
Realize, when there is a
machine that's been compromised,
that means somebody
has figured out
how to take advantage of it.
And so in some form
or another, if you
log into a machine that's
knowingly compromised,
you are in some way handing
over credentials to an attacker.
So don't have the
inclination to do that.
Now these two things
are very important
because the rest of this talk
is going to be largely centered
around, so what do I do?
You know, how do I get
around these things?
I do want to know what's going
on in these environments.
But generally speaking,
don't log in and then
sort of say, you know, I know a
thing or two about top and grep
and ps, and I can look at logs.
It's not our general plan.
So the bulk of today.
The bulk of today is
collecting things.
Like we said, resources
and the professionals that
are going to come in to
do this work for you,
you could either say, I have no
idea what's in my environment.
Please take a look.
Here are my credentials.
Go ahead.
And they're going to
start from square one.
Not only does that cost
you time and money,
it's just not an
efficient use of time.
We're trying to get folks
out of our infrastructure.
So we're going to go
through collection.
We want, as part of our
preparation process, things
that we're going to
have done ahead of time
is to be collecting
a lot of information
so that when something
happens, we're going to say,
yes, you're finding a
needle in a haystack,
but we've really curated
the haystack down
to make it a very
small bundle of things.
We think there's
something in here.
We think what you're
going to find is in here.
Please take a look.
And it's generally
these three buckets--
logs, disks, and
live information.
Live information
because more and more,
we're not in a
situation where we're
dealing with infected or
compromised hosts that
are sitting under our desks or
sitting inside of our office.
We're in Cloud.
So in Cloud, you don't
have that liberty, right?
You have to think about how
to do things over the wire,
over the internet.
And so, more and more, we
need tools and mechanisms
to connect to things
while they're online,
while they're on the network.
So generally we're going to go
through activities for the rest
of this talk that are talking
about how to collect logs,
what to do about getting
disks-- disks are obviously one
of the most central
pieces of information
in an analyst's job--
and then how to collect
information real-time,
live over the network.
Before we collect
anything, though, we
want to put things into
a secured location.
We don't want to collect all
these buckets of information
and then have that
bucket be a leaky bucket.
We want to basically
put them into a vault.
And that vault-- if you think
about the Google project
organization, you're
going to have projects.
Your projects are where
your services are running,
things that are talking
to the internet,
and this is where your, quote
unquote, "compromised" activity
might be happening.
But on the other side of that,
your security apparatus within
your organization, those who
are responsible for collecting
these artifacts, they should
have their own highly isolated
environment-- a
separate project--
and that's designated
for artifacts.
And it's a one-way
flow of information
and we're going to set it up
so that the only folks that
have access to that is
a highly sort of refined
list of individuals.
This isn't something even that
most people should know exist.
But set this up
first so that we have
a destination for everything.
So logs was the first
thing in our agenda.
Logs is a broad category.
Anybody that's had to
troubleshoot a problem
knows that logs is
your best asset.
And within Cloud
platform, there's
sort of two camps of logs.
There's logs that
we generate as part
of Google that
tell you everything
about your environment.
And these are admin
activity logs,
so who launched an instance,
who modified a firewall rule,
and data access.
So if you're using any of our
data products, like BigQuery,
and you're storing all your
customer data on BigQuery,
well, that becomes
a tangible asset
that's a vector for somebody
to try to come in and attack.
So we can log activities
regarding your data access.
So we take care of that.
These are
platform-generated logs.
The other side of
the fence is logs
that you generate-- logs that
your application generates.
And so we're going to
talk about basically
each one of these
individually and where you
should destine these things.
So the nice thing is that,
within Cloud platform,
there is a facility called
Stackdriver Logging.
This is how we surface all
log information to you.
But it's not simply for the
platform-generated logs.
It's a full-fledged
logging service.
And this is where you would
instrument and say, hey,
I'm going to be generating
logs from my instances.
logs from my application.
Those are all going
to basically end up
in the same monolithic point.
Now if you have another logging
instrument, that's fine,
but the point is, you
should be sending all logs
to some centralized place that
allows you to pivot and look
at it.
Now the platform-generated
logs, like I said,
those are just given
to you automatically.
They make their way into
Stackdriver Logging.
But you have to do
a couple of things
in order to get user
logs and application
logs into that environment.
So we'll talk about it as three
phases, ingest, filtering,
and export.
So ingest is really simple.
It's actually a very
frictionless thing.
When you're creating
your VMs or when
you're creating
your environment,
make sure to install a
Stackdriver Logging agent.
It's the logging agent that's
essentially a packaged Fluentd
agent.
And that's really
all you have to do.
It's preconfigured to look at
all the standard normal places
within your operating system--
your syslog and
other activities.
And as soon as it
turns on, it's going
to be able to use
instance information,
authenticate, and send it to
the Stackdriver Logging API.
You can do this from AWS as well
and install the logging agent
on your EC2 instances and
it will go effectively
to one destination.
In your application
code, we have
support for several
different languages
essentially in your
application code.
Instead of one approach would
maybe just to be logging out
to the system level logging.
The other is, your application
code directly could instrument
talking to the Stackdriver API.
And so you've got the sort of
async process, which is just
sending out log information.
If you're running in
serverless or you're
running in an environment
where you can't necessarily
rely on collecting
the system-level logs,
you want to emit those logs
directly from your application,
then you would simply
turn around-- we
all left a lot of
samples on how to include
logging capabilities within
your application co-directly.
And those don't necessarily
need to go through the operating
system.
Once it's in Stackdriver
Logging-- and Stackdriver
Logging, I'm not making sort
of any claims about sort
of the volume of logs and
the cost of logs and things
like that.
That's obviously something you
should estimate and figure out
how long data should sit
there and where it should move
and how much it will cost.
But the nice thing is, once
it's in Stackdriver Logging,
by and large, you get this
sort of freeform search.
You can do advanced filters,
you can do custom filters,
you can look at
different things--
like if you wanted to know
why a particular server is out
of sync, you could
run it and simply
look for what the
NTP daemon was doing
on a particular instance or all
instances at a certain time.
And this is going to be really
instrumental later in the talk
where we show you can do some
fancy things with filtering
that will tell you, hey, there's
something fishy going on.
But most likely, this
is sort of a pit stop.
Stackdriver Logging
is a pit stop
on the way to
something different.
We want to save these logs.
Like I said, the order of
magnitude on these attacks
is not a couple
of days or weeks.
Sometimes we're finding out
they're months or years.
And so we want a destination to
send these logs to long-term.
Stackdriver Logging
gives you three outlets
to send your information out to.
BigQuery, which is kind
of like the choice I
would sort of default here, the
logs are already structured.
That lends very nicely to
export them to BigQuery, where
they will already be searchable
and they will already
be able to query against.
But then, if you ever
wanted them out of BigQuery
in, say, a flat file format,
you can always do an Unload
operation out of BigQuery.
You could just send them
flat out to Cloud Storage,
or you could send
them to Pub/Sub.
Those two queues cases are
interesting because those of us
who are operating another type
of logging infrastructure,
whether you're operating
Splunk or something like that,
or you have a SIM.
Your SoC is leveraging
a SIM and you
want to basically
say, no, I have
several different environments.
I want everything
to go into that SIM.
This is where you would
pivot that information.
You would say, OK,
drop it into a bucket
and I'll set up a
bucket trigger and I'll
know to basically pull
that information in.
In the case of
Splunk and others,
if you send it to
Pub/Sub, they're
able to hook into that Pub/Sub
feed and bring things over.
But the point is-- the
objective is-- to move it out.
What does look like from
a technical perspective?
We do something called
setting up syncs,
and the sync just basically
says, hey, Stackdriver,
I know the data is inside
of the Stackdriver platform.
I want it out.
And so you can, in a very
terse amount of language,
you can say what is the
log that I'm interesting
in-- essentially
set up the filter--
and where do I want it to go.
What Stackdriver will
do is turn around
and say, OK, I'll go ahead
and create that for you.
Here's a specific service
account within your environment
that's going to be
used for the sync.
And go ahead and if you've
asked for it in this case
to go to BigQuery, notice
these are not necessarily
in the same project because
we have our forensics project,
we have our security project
where all this data is going.
And so it's important to turn
around and go to the data
set or the bucket
or wherever you're
destining this
information and say, oh, I
need to take that service
account that Stackdriver told
me it was going
to use and I need
to grant it the
appropriate permission
to be able to write to that.
So this is great.
If you do this, you've got
this kind of automated.
Every instance comes up.
You make it part of
the bootstrap process
that every instance is
going to be able to send
this information off.
But this test tells
us syslog information.
Syslog information is great
in terms of standard system
activities.
It's not perfectly useful if
you want to go much deeper.
If you want to go at
the forensic level,
we need to look at, OK,
what is this instance doing?
What are the system calls
that are being made?
Who's asking for different
things to happen?
So we need to go and upgrade
the amount of information
we're getting from an instance.
So within Linux,
there's something
called the Linux
auditing system, which
is something you can tap into.
Every single activity-- there's
something like 300-odd sys
calls that are being
done within Linux,
but you can look at
every single activity.
You can look at
every time somebody
touched a certain file,
read a certain file.
You can look at when somebody
has asked to open a socket
or listen on a socket.
So this is when somebody
has asked to run something
with privileged information.
This information is actually
there and being emitted
from the kernel all the time.
There's a mechanism where
the kernel sends it over
to the user space for some
tool to do what with it--
the kernel doesn't
really dictate that.
It uses something called
a netlink socket and says,
I'm just going to dump this
as a flood of information
out on this.
And so you can have things
that listen for that
and pull it off.
Auditd is one such tool.
Another such tool
would be osquery.
The tool is really sort of your
preference and your choice,
but the point is, you
need something in userland
to basically subscribe to that
and take that off and then send
it, in this case, to logging.
So we need to instrument that
a couple of different ways,
which I'll show in a
second, but in this case,
every time somebody has
done something privileged--
in this case, somebody has
done something using sudo
and we're interested in that--
that goes to
Stackdriver Logging.
Because we've pre-filled out
the collection part of this
with an agent, then essentially
we just need to say,
yep, this is one more
thing I wanted to learn.
Without this kind
of information,
it's very, very
hard to really get
a picture of what
the instance was
doing-- what the VM was doing.
You'll sort of maybe
see some startup times,
some application launch times,
but without actually looking
at kernel-level activities
or audit-level activities,
you may not necessarily know,
like, who did what in what
sense.
Getting this onto an instance
is pretty straightforward,
pretty trivial.
If you think about
the previous slides,
we showed, hey, you would
have a startup script.
Install the Stackdriver
Logging agent.
Great.
Pretty much with
one command, you'd
get all the Stackdriver Logging.
It's about the same here.
Well I guess there's a
few more than one command.
It's like a long command.
So there's a couple of
different things here.
One is we already
sort of acknowledged
that we're going to have
a Stackdriver Logging
agent ready to go, but we're
going to pull down auditd
and we need to do
a couple of things.
One is we need to-- in
that top little block
in the audit rules,
that's where we tell
auditd what am I interested in.
So this is about the version
that would fit on a slide.
It's not necessarily
meant to be prescriptive.
You'd want to do some
research on auditd
and see what kind of
calls are meaningful to be
able to look at.
In this case, we're
saying, tell me
everything that has
an effective UID of 0.
Like, basically
tell me anything,
like on the previous
slide, that was being
executed with sudo or as root.
The other thing we need to
do-- the back half of that--
is great, we're generating
all this information.
It's going into audit log.
Stackdriver by
default doesn't know
that this is a source
of logging that we'd
like to also include with the
logs that come off of this box.
So that end piece
there that says--
is a configuration that
says, hey, Stackdriver,
go ahead and pay attention
to this new log format
that I've dropped out.
And by the way, it's
a little bit special.
It uses some key value pairs.
It has to be parsed a certain
way in order to make it in.
So that's what that
format key value is.
But if you do this, great.
You've got everything that's
happening from a syslog
perspective.
You've got everything
down to everything
that the kernel
is thinking about.
So in terms of
logging positions,
we've got our platform logs.
We've got our data access logs.
We've got our OS logs, our
application server logs.
We've got everything that's
happening on the instance
and now we know what's
going down to the kernel.
The last kind of
piece of this is--
from a logging perspective--
is flow logs.
Flow logs essentially tell you--
I've just finished
describing everything that's
going on inside of an instance.
Everything that's going on
from a platform perspective
around an instance.
This sort of rounds
out the piece.
So tell me everything that's
happening from a network
perspective.
Everything that's from a
network passing-- and I
think somebody mentioned looking
for spurious network patterns--
everything that's
being thrown back
and forth across our instances.
And this is not on by default.
This is pretty chatty.
It's a lot of data.
It's a lot of traffic.
But it's something
that you would
want to look at turning on.
So you would go in your
subnet and you'd basically
say "turn flow logs
on" and it's going
to score every TCP and UDP
flow, with some caveats.
If it's a single
packet type thing--
it's based on sampling, so
in some sampling senses,
it may not pick up on very, very
low packet-- like single packet
count type things-- but if
you've got something that's
steadying a stream out, which
is what a lot of attacks do,
this would be a good
way to pick up on it.
And because it's in
Stackdriver Logging,
I can formulate
this search pattern.
Now here, obviously
everybody recognizes this.
This is a great DNS
server to be using.
This is Google's DNS server.
So this isn't
necessarily suspicious.
What would be suspicious,
though, is in your environment
if you're like, why do I have
any outbound DNS traffic?
I have centralized DNS
within my environment.
Instances kind of look inward.
Why am I sending DNS
traffic out to the internet?
And there are some
exploits that are actually
pretty well-known now that
take advantage of exactly that
using DNS tunneling or DNScat.
They're able to sort
of compromise a machine
and say, make it look
like a DNS query,
but every time you make
the query, just piggyback
on this little tidbit
of information.
And over time, that
information gets
accumulated on the other side.
So this may be a very
interesting query,
not necessarily going to Google
but going out to somewhere
that you didn't expect.
All right.
That is the entirety
of logging--
what the platform is
doing, what your data
is doing, what the instance
is doing, very deep,
and what's happening around it.
So that kind of rounds out our
picture of logging-- collecting
that information, putting
it in that logging basket,
and having it be
searchable because you've
sent it to a
searchable endpoint.
You've sent it to something
not only in Stackdriver Logging
that you can query with
some advance queries,
you've sent it to BigQuery.
Now you'll be able to
say, you know what?
I think I need to
zone in on everything
that was running on a
particular managed instance
group or anything with
this particular tag
or anything with Service A.
You've got a point to basically
come in and say,
great, I'm going
to carve out that set
of logs and the traffic
patterns and the
kernel activities
and send that somewhere.
We'll talk about where
to send it in a second.
Disks.
So this is usually the
canonical forensic,
"hey, I'm going to do an
investigation" activity.
Grab the disks and send it to
somebody that may or may not
look at them.
So we grab the disks
and look at it.
So obviously in a
Cloud environment,
we don't have the
disk grab API yet,
where you can tell a
human being to grab it,
but that's not what you want.
Really what you
want is the disk.
And if you remember the don'ts--
the things not to do-- is
do this in an obtrusive way.
We don't want to do this in
a way that reveals that we're
doing something investigatory.
Logs happen saliently.
All those agents,
as long as you make
those part of your build-up,
your bootstrap process,
all that information is
spewing and nobody is really
the wiser from an attacker
perspective of how much
information is being sent off.
I mean, they probably
perceivably look,
but you're not instrumenting
something after their attack.
It's just part of
the normal process.
Disks are the same way.
We don't want to terminate disks
and say, oh no, but it's OK.
I just had to save the disk.
We want a much more salient
way to instrument this.
We want to use Cloud APIs to
do this a little bit better.
So what this process would
look like, or does look like,
is to enumerate the
instance or instances
that you are interested in.
OK, Service A is compromised or
Microservice B is compromised.
What are all the instances
that are running that?
Come up with a list of disks
attached to those instances,
and behind the scenes, use
a platform to make a copy.
And those copies
exist in logical form
from an object perspective
within your Cloud account.
What we want is a
tangible artifact
that can be sent to
a downstream tool.
So what does that look like?
It's actually just
three commands.
It is possible to take a
running disk that's attached
and make a snapshot from it.
The reason to make a snapshot
is because these disks
are attached.
If you wanted to make--
it's a prerequisite
for the next step, which
is to create a disk
image from a source.
So you can create a disk
image from a persistent disk,
but if that persistent disk
is attached, we can't do it.
So first we take a
snapshot, we create
a point in time of a
disk that's attached,
we create a disk image
from that snapshot,
and then we can export
that disk image.
Now this may be something
interesting just from your own
operational perspective--
how do I get information
that's running--
how do I get a disk image
that's running on production
and have a backup
copy in case I need
to change environments or
do something interesting?
But this is incredibly
effective because we
can create an entire
external archive
in the form of a file
that can be pulled
into another tool for analysis.
Again, an attacker
that's running something
on an instance you're
running has no idea
that this activity took place.
OK.
That was it for disks.
It's really, really
straightforward and simple.
It's one of the biggest
things that you'll
do in your analysis activity.
But I'd like to move on to the
last part of the puzzle, which
is-- the last part of
the things we collect,
which is live information.
Again, we need to talk to
environments that are up.
And so we're sort of
done with the things
that the platform and some
agents and bootstrapping
can do.
We're going to move on to,
like, how do I look at something
that is going on in the box?
You've been informed
there's a compromise.
You know there's an
instance that's compromised.
I want to log in.
I can't log in because that
would give my credentials away.
But clearly there's
something running in memory
on that box that's
sending data out.
So GRR is an agent-based system.
It actually installs on
Windows, MacOS, Linux.
It's an open-source project that
started at Google a while ago.
It's actually GRR
Rapid Response.
To be cool, you say "grr."
I was talking with some of
the folks that contribute
and create to it and
I kept saying G-R-R
and they said that
I wasn't cool enough
to give the talk because
I don't say "grr."
So say "grr" to be cool.
GRR know-before-you-go.
With great power comes--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SAMI ZUHURUDDIN:
No, that's wrong.
So it's a lot of
extensive capability.
It can let you do
literally anything.
And so it is that sharp
end of the spear upon which
you can do pretty much anything
inside your environment,
so it's probably a good idea
to fortify the heck out of it.
Effectively, it is
the point at which
you could be root on anything
and look at anything.
So there is an entire--
in the GRR readthedocs
there's an entire section
on how to secure it.
You know, how do
you front-end it,
how do you put the
right certificates on.
That would be an
entire talk on its own.
This is just my way to make
sure that Google security
people don't yell at me.
But secure it
before you move on.
OK.
Once you've got
GRR up and running,
there are two main activities--
clients will report
into it but there's
two sort of main things
you would ask GRR to do,
a flow or a hunt.
And so a flow is just
an atomic unit of work.
You're like, hey,
that box right there,
I'd like to look at
a particular file.
That box right there,
I'd like to look
at the memory that's running
on that particular process.
So GRR can essentially
start a flow
and say, great, who
do you want to target?
What do you want to
do on that machine?
And then that machine would pull
in and ask if there's any work.
A hunt would be sort of
under this new banner
of threat hunting.
If you just sort of
go from a premise
that you're always
compromised, there's
something always going
on in your environment,
then you may say,
you know, I know
that there's this shape of
this jar that's pretty bad
or I know there's
this string that's
pretty indicative
of a compromise
and I want to be hunting
my fleet for any time that
shows up.
So this is an example
of a GRR flow.
I've asked for a
process memory dump.
So let's say, for example,
you have a machine.
An attacker's on the machine
and says, you know, rudimentary,
I'm just going to
actually take this file.
I'm going to dump the
entire creditcards.zip--
no, don't ever do that.
I'm going to take
that and basically
make it look like
some system-level file
because I've made it
look like a swap file,
and I'm going to just
send it over a socket.
I've only got 20
minutes on this box.
And so you could send this over.
And so now you've
got this process
which is online,
which is active,
which is egressing information.
You're like, hey, that
doesn't look right.
So you start a flow
and say, I would
like to dump that process.
So GRR will turn
around, and then
when that box makes contacts,
it will say, hey, turn around
and run this flow.
And so you'll see in the GRR
console, it's like, OK, cool.
I brought this piece of work
here you've asked me to do.
And it will go on and collect,
and then a few moments later,
you'll see that, hey,
GRR, say I'm done.
I'm done collecting this memory.
I've stored in these
however many little artifact
files-- these files.
You're ready to
come check it out--
sort of like your dry
cleaning is ready to pick up.
And so you can pull
those files down.
And they're files that represent
the binary representation
of what's in memory, so
you could do something
as simple as run
strings on it, which
would take that
binary information
and turn it back
into text, and you
could see that essentially
what I had sent was sitting--
whatever you had been
sending was sitting resident
in memory for that
process still.
It hadn't been
garbage collected yet.
And you would be able
to dump that out.
And so it's pretty powerful
to be able to say, look,
I can actually look and
reach inside of a box
and look at the memory
that's going on inside of it.
It's not necessarily
going to be this easy.
This is trivialized.
But the point I'm
trying to make here
is, without GRR, you
couldn't do this.
Remember, you're hamstrung.
Your hands are tied behind your
back because you can't log in.
You don't want to log in.
You know that's
just a bad practice.
But with GRR, at least
you can effectively
do everything you would need
to do had you been logged in.
GRR actually is designed to
go onto agents, like Windows
machines, MacOS machines,
machines that are out
on the internet-- the
agents are available--
and be contacted from, say,
a fleet of workstations
that you're managing.
But in a cloud deployment
here, for using
in this sort of
centralized context
where you're having
machines-- instances spin up
in different projects
and contact in,
we'd want to make it work
in this sort of, again,
segmented approach, where not
everybody has access to the GRR
server.
It is a pull model,
so the nice thing,
it's not GRR reaching
out and making contacts
and you having to
deal with firewalls
in every single instance.
Agents on
client-installed machines
pull periodically for activity.
And the nice thing is,
then, if they're offline,
they're offline, but when they
come online, they'll say, hey,
do you have any work for me?
And the other thing
GRR does is it has
customized install binaries.
And so you'll put those
binaries in a specific bucket
and you'll set up your
internal firewall rules.
But the way to do this sort of
cross-project-- because again,
we want our security
artifacts and infrastructure
in a different project
than our production ones--
we'd want to set up
VPC peering here.
So this isn't really that
much of an interesting slide,
but essentially,
it's a few steps.
You can set up peering between
two pieces of infrastructure.
And the main thing
there is to make
sure you allow the relevant
protocols into your GRR server.
The GRR server itself is
pretty easy to set up.
It's got Debian packages.
It comes with Docker--
I mean, you can
download a Docker image
and run a Docker image.
Part of the setup will
interrogate you and ask you,
what is the name
by which clients
are going to contact me?
And you configure all
that information in.
What is the admin
interface going to be on?
You configure all
that information
in as part of the setup, and
then as it's doing the setup,
it will build custom
install binaries.
So it isn't something--
and this is really salient
because then these install
binaries are just ready to go.
So you'd put those
into a bucket.
That's basically where they
sit on the management console.
And what you want to
do, then, is any piece
of infrastructure in
your environment--
any compute that needs to
grab those binaries-- just
make sure you give those
access to the bucket.
And that's it.
It's sort of a one pull-- you
know, pull down the archive
from a bucket using gsutil
and then install it.
So now we've kind of
talked about three things
in our install script--
Stackdriver Logging agent,
auditd, and now the GRR agent.
With this, we've got
our logging information,
we've talked about
disk collection,
and we've talked about
getting information
using live information.
So let's move on to detection.
This is kind of where
it starts to get real.
We're in a good position here.
We're in a position
that if somebody said,
tell me everything that
goes on in your environment,
and you, instead of
looking at them like a deer
in headlights, which
is easy to do up here
with lights in your face--
instead of that, you
can go, I got this.
I can pull a disk for you.
I can tell you what's
going on in memory.
I can pull logs related
to that incident.
I can bundle this all
together and hand it over.
And so, in detecting
this, this is
where you would employ
any number of services.
Maybe you're
hunting for malware.
Maybe you're noticing that your
instances are beaconing out
to some-- you know, trying to
make contact with the command
or control server.
Your IDS pro picks it up.
Unexpected processes
was called out earlier
on unauthorized sys calls.
Why is something trying
to listen on a port?
So let's say you put
that all together.
This is an example of
what a pipeline on Cloud
could look like--
a forensics pipeline.
If you remember
in the beginning,
I said we'd sort of pull
all of this together
to make it look interesting.
But imagine you have an
instance that's beaconing.
It's sending out to
some bad known IP.
So before the fact, you've sort
of sourced a list of bad IPs.
We'll talk about
that in a second.
And so you've got the machine
beaconing, which you're
able to find out because
that's going into Flow Logs,
and you've got a list of bad
IPs that you've configured
as a filter because
you're like, hey,
I can configure a filter
to look for certain IPs.
And if you notice
that, you could
tell some worker process
that says, you know,
this doesn't look right.
I want you to
trigger off of that
and I want you to go
and collect everything
you know about that instance.
And because Flow Logs
are fairly chatty
and that would keep
repeating, you'd probably
checkpoint these
results somewhere
and say, oh, this is
instance demo one.
It's been compromised.
You don't want to kick
off this flow every time,
so you'd maybe collect that
information in Firestore,
and Firestore has a few
different ways to use it.
The way we're talking
about here is closed.
You don't want Firestore
open to mobile and web.
You know, this is just
basically a holding ground for--
it's not a social app.
It's just a holding ground
to checkpoint your results.
And so I would turn around
and I would do that.
I would say, collect me
the memory, grab the disks,
run this query to collect all
the logs for that instance,
then send those
to the next stage.
And the next stage would
be, I've got the memory.
What do you want me to do?
Kick off another process which
turns around and analyzes
that with Volatility
or Rekall or something.
And I've got all these
time-based artifacts--
I've got disks.
I've got logs.
I want to put those together
in a way I can look at them.
You create what's called
a super timeline, which
is using some tools called
Plaso and Timesketch--
and oh, by the way, as
this activity was running,
one feature of
Stackdriver Logging
is that you can use alerting.
And alerting can then not only
alert based on some metric,
it can do notifications with
PagerDuty and other things.
And so your incident
response team gets an alert.
It comes in and says,
hey, this bucket
has a bunch of
artifacts, or these VMs
have a bunch of artifacts
that have been loaded up
in their analysis tools.
They need your eyeballs
on them right away.
So this is not
fictitious, actually.
You can build this
with everything
we've already talked about
and a lot of the things
we've already shown,
but I'll kind of just
allude to the things we
haven't quite talked about.
So MSP is an organization,
SANSes are organizations.
These are well-known
organizations
that help collate and curate
bad actor information,
malware information, and
so they do have the ability
to sort of bring down a list.
It could be earlier, like we
talked about with DNS, where
it's maybe a particular port
that you know is troublesome,
but in this case,
you could say, well,
I just want to download
the top bad actor list.
And because we're able to set
up syncs programmatically,
like we set up earlier
a sync for archive,
this is a sync that's different.
You'll notice the destination
is actually Pub/Sub.
And we'd set up a topic
here called, hey, beaconing.
I think that if I see somebody
talking to these bad IPs,
it's a pretty good indication
that they're beaconing out
to make contact with someone.
And so I could build this
list and sort of refresh this
on a basis, and if
it triggers, boom.
I'm going to send it
to a Pub/Sub topic
and that will kick
off the activities
that you saw in
that worker chain.
So this payload comes
in and that worker says,
what do you want me to do?
Well it turns out,
GRR has an API,
and so if this was
the worker that's
going to orchestrate
the GRR activity,
it would say, cool, what's in
the payload of this message
that I just got on Pub/Sub?
And the two things that
are interesting there
are the source IP and
the destination IP.
So the first thing I would do
is I would contact the GRR API
and I would say, give me
the client that has this IP.
And so GRR would search
its database and say,
here's a client or
here's a list of clients.
And then the next
thing, which is
more interesting, I would
say, go do a netstat
on that machine.
Go do a netstat and tell me
in that netstat who's talking
to this bad IP-- what process.
Give me the PID of the process
talking to this bad IP.
And then it would come
back and say, well, here's
the PID of who's talking to
that IP based on the netstat.
Great.
Go dump me in the
memory for that PID.
I want to know everything
that's happening
in the memory on that PID
that's talking to that bad IP
because it shouldn't be.
This is all done just basically
talking and interacting
with the GRR API.
And it started
off with a trigger
that was based on
some information
that we can easily source.
The next thing in our
pipeline after memory
was building a timeline.
The timeline
essentially just says,
when you can take
a bunch of data
and extract the
metadata that has
to do with time on that
timeline and lay it all out.
You lay it all out so that
it's chronologically able
to be analyzed and then
layer on anything else that
has that time
element because we're
sort of hunting and
finding a cataclysmic event
and looking sort of
around that and around
that to say, ah, that's
where that file was dropped
and that's where that
process was launched.
That file was dropped on the
disk based on this information
and that process
was launched based
on this user at this time.
We want all that information.
So we take all our logs,
anything that's time-sensitive,
and our disks.
We send them to log2timeline and
it creates a super timeline--
a Plaso file.
A Plaso file would
just be a file that
would be sort of hard
to look at and sort of
like a spreadsheet
fashion, and so we
want a way to sort of bring
that together and collaborate.
So there's another
tool called Timesketch.
Timesketch was
written by a Google
engineer named Johan Berggren.
I hope I'm saying that right.
And it sort of has this--
it's ElasticSearch backed
but it has this ability
to load in all this timeline
information into sketches
and say, hey, I want
to bring in timelines.
What this does is it's a focal
point for all your analysts
to sort of look at and say,
there is interesting traffic
right there.
I want to annotate that.
I want to come back to
that in my workflow.
I want to look at how that
event connects to other events.
And so you can do sort of all
that collaborative exercise
with Timesketch, and you can
have multiple of these going on
if you have different events
going on at different times.
So how do I bring things
into Plaso and Timesketch?
Well I'd set up Plaso.
I'd set up Timesketch.
I'd copy down the disk image
after acquiring a disk image.
I'd run log2timeline.
I'd create a timeline.
I'd basically do
a bunch of stuff.
And so what would be
great is if I didn't have
to do all of this stuff, right?
If somehow, this could
all be sequenced together
where I could interact
with the Cloud APIs
and interact with all
these forensic analysis
tools and sort of
pull it together.
And so I want to highlight
a couple of tools
in closing here.
Is Turbinia and Timewolf.
These are open-source projects.
They are used by certain
teams here at Google as well,
but they are available.
And so Turbinia
is, if you recall,
like, hey, this activity.
I want to create a Timesketch.
I want to create a Plaso.
I have this memory
in these files
and I want to run strings on it.
So when you have
forensic artifacts
and you want to run an
activity against those forensic
artifacts, this
is where you would
orchestrate that with Turbinia.
But you also notice in
this whole pipeline--
that whole long
sequence of things--
I was sequencing
between different APIs
in this process of building
my forensic pipeline.
And that's where a
tool like dfTimewolf
comes in, where it can say it's
the plumbing or the glue that
kind of pulls together disparate
actions between these APIs
in the goal of being
able to kick off
these more finer activities,
say, in Turbinia.
So those are two tools
you can look at that lean
very heavily into Cloud APIs.
A question might be, hey, you've
talked about all the things
in VM world.
How does this pertain to
new computing environments,
like containers and serverless?
And a lot of the
things are applicable.
In the serverless camp,
actually, very little
is applicable because you don't
have control over the execution
environment.
You don't get the logs
from that environment.
But we do get a standard out.
You know, that's generally what
a serverless environment will
pull out for you,
is that it will
send to you whatever your
environment was sending--
standard out.
But in containers,
there are some things
we need to keep on top of.
If we're looking at
the sys call activity,
there is some
utilities like Sysdig,
or you could use gVisor.
There's a talk tomorrow here
in this room, I think at 10:20,
on gVisor, which
is, how do I look
at what a container is doing?
And gVisor kind of
goes a step beyond
and not only looks at
what a container can
do in terms of sys calls
but it can sandbox those.
So you'd sort of
have a white list of,
like, what should this
container be able to do?
But because it's sandboxing and
intercepting those sys calls,
it actually can
log off of those.
So if that sounds interesting,
attend that talk tomorrow.
GVisor was open-sourced
by Google recently
and it's super interesting.
And there's a couple
of different ways
to run on Container Engine.
One is using
Container-Optimized OS,
and then the other is Ubuntu.
And so if you want to sort of
install any of these things
or work with the base
operating system,
that generally means you're
going to pick Ubuntu.
And then the VMs are basically
everything we talked about.
But it's probably helpful to
sort of look at this compare
and contrast aspect.
OK.
So bottom line is-- sort
of a leave-behind is that--
don't go into panic
mode when something
happens-- when you've been
alerted to something going on.
Have a plan and
say the analysis is
going to show that this
information can be found out
by looking at certain
data, and that data
is going to be your
logs, your disks,
and your live information.
And have that ready to
curate and pull together.
So when something
happens, follow the plan.
Gather data.
Use the tools mentioned
to collaborate.
It will take many
folks working together
to sort of pull all the
information together and find
that needle in a haystack.
And then again,
be sure you bring
in folks that know
what they're doing
or have been trained to
know what to look for.
So if the patterns in this
talk seemed interesting to you
and they are some of the
things that you look to employ,
we'll be probably
publishing these
in the form of a solution--
I work on solutions that I
publish out to the community
and I'll probably try
to publish these out,
but if you want to get in touch
before then and sort of talk
about these patterns,
please reach out
at next18-forensics@google.com.
So thank you and
I hope you enjoy
the rest of the conference.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]